Danny worry to have you here at the
london film and comic con such an
incredible career obviously so many
movies over the years which particularly
stand out for you is most memorable
which have you enjoyed them a place in
the heart stands at the top because my
work is dedicated to my mother that film
we love it um Grand Canyon there's so
many you know I've been fortunate you
know to have so many and color purple
tour yeah what is it about those
particular films that hold up their
place in your heart well I'm now working
in in pleasing hardens for my mother
don't love the feelings are brought to
that to the role of moes where my images
of my grandfather you know my mother's
father yeah you know there was just
incredible people my head you know I'm
from the city but I spent so much in my
type in the sound on my grandparents
farm so I'm four I'm een how fortuitous
it was that that my first major role was
that and it gave me an opportunity to
play you know playing homage to pay
homage to you know where I come from you
know and come out of what a beautiful
opportunity yeah you ready get that in
charge of movies yeah yeah amazing way
to start i'm posting it of course the
lethal weapon movies there as well been
so beloved by many many people all over
the world what was the experience like
of making those because obviously you
made four of them didn't you total fun
working with every single one from you
know richard donner and joel silver
producers and director
now gets in the car Joe Pesci everyone
who's been a part of it you know been in
great great great great great and
there's been rumors over the years
haven't no Wilda BF it's lethal weapon
film would you like to see another one
would you want to be involved at all you
know the lesson 15 years ago i'm 15
years older and melted in years old or
young i think the first war the first
floor with him within a 12 year period
and so everything we did was believable
to a certain extent you know we'd be
stretching it oh but be honest you know
but hey never know yeah you have had a
lot of people coming back like diehard
haven't we in this I was in die hard
come back and we've had some Middle star
wars guys gonna come back that's what
they were back but you know I mean I
mean males made a great career using the
pier Aletha weapons the platform you
know I've been able to do that
and justice you know
No
no Harrison Ford has made a great career
out of doing ridges that allows our
that's great finally I know you've got
loads of movies coming out what in
particular you're looking forward to
what can we look forward to next from
you Danny there's some nice stuff I did
something with HBO and about Muhammad
Ali that's really something we excited
about I did a movie with danny trejo you
know badass yeah that's something that's
gonna be having fun with so it's all
great okay we look forward slows down
it's been lovely speaking to you thank
thank you thank you
you